le camp de basket est le week-end prochain tu as
un potentiel incroyable sur le terrain et je peux
t'aider à y arriver
ce n'est pas ce que je veux papa
tu ne me laisses jamais faire ce que je veux faire
tu ne me laisses jamais me faire
tenir le mauvais étage
qui va me forger  je dois faire face à ça
quoi dans l'enfer de la matrice
[Musique]
bienvenue roi james je suis le roi de ce
domaine
c'est le verset du serveur qu'as-tu fait
à mon fils où est dom
la seule façon de récupérer ton
fils est si  toi et moi jouons un peu au
basket pete envoie ce clown aux
rejets
équipe de rêve
madame tirez sur la balle
essayons à nouveau allons-nous
roi james
[musique]
présenter
et récupérer notre fils
beurk
classique bienvenue dans le camp spatial
[musique]
bienvenue dans le space jam
vous